we're here to talk about your new film
private pizza which is set during World
War one and George in particular you're
no stranger to wartime dramas are you
you go quite a few into your name so how
did private peaceful compared to your
experience on things like Defiant's and
birdsong and also the best of men too
yeah well I mean define Sandburg song
where the Second World War and different
with France was like a partisan army and
then that Russia and best was post or
what kind of mid woman he was in
hospital carry this army with with
private peaceful the word if it was I
think it was again with this is such a
personal thing that's being completely
driven by the relationships they have
within the film and so the war was a bad
job and very important scenario
obviously for them to be and that's what
the drum kind of circulates around but
when it really circulates is the love of
brotherhood and enough emollient and
kind of and all the complexities have
wanted to be a man all this stuff so it
was I think it acted more as a backdrop
it worked and we were saying you know if
there wasn't as much kind of necessarily
the research before of knowing exactly
what it would have been like and how it
was obviously we did some of that but it
was we wanted to come in quite fresh as
these boys would of not knowing how to
hold a rifle and what it would be like
when we went over the top and so so I
mean my experience of doing this kind of
war what some things I think a lot more
personal a lot more and I'm vivid
because we were doing it it felt much
more real because we were doing people
we really cared about this night and
Danny's not as well and George both your
characters in the film and along with
Jack as well you have a great bond
between you don't you that's very
important that comes across on the
screen how did you guys kind of develop
that and bring it to life on the big
screen um well we were production put us
in this hotel in the middle of nowhere
in Ipswich in a little village called
lead and where there's one powered one
shop and I said to that our hotel and so
we there was nothing else to do but hang
out together and get to know each other
we would just and you know we'd have
breakfast together we'd go and rehearse
and film together we'd come back and
we'd eat together we'd hang out and we'd
go you know sometimes dancing in Ipswich
together and that sort of I'm the
dynamic between the three of us changed
you know when other people came into it
like the other boys when they were
filming with us but when I started
filming Jack and George had been
together for two weeks by themselves so
they were really really close it was
quite intimidating for me to come into
it and that their dynamic changed when I
came in and then yeah I just you know
they're actors that I have admired
anyway so just to get to work with them
was yeah was a privilege I'm told you
that and also you working with what are
your favorite actresses as well this one
who's playing George's mum and Maxine P
how is that again cuz I mean you have a
relationship with her from from drama
school then yes she was at am i
allocated drama buddy when you graduate
you get given a buddy at Rada and she
was mine so she's been in my phonebook
and at the end of the form for me a lot
of times at the start of my career when
I've been unsure of what to do in a walk
job to do so she's always been there and
then she rang me I was like I've been
offered this job is called private
peaceful as I do it yes do it and so
yeah it was it was really strange to be
on a set with her and get to see her
work because I always you know get to
see your artwork and I remember there
was just one shot where me and Jack
they'll have in this argument and she
comes up and in rehearsals you know she
was just marking it through an unsaid
she's gonna be like when the cameras
rolling and as soon as they said action
she just like she just comes alive I
just love watching actresses like I find
it really inspiring and talking about
the people who are playing your family
members and so he also had younger
versions of you the mini hungover
Molly's didn't you on seeing the child
act as you played your part how did you
work with them did you work with them at
all to create that kind of flow from
childhood to your adult characters I
think
well we didn't we didn't actually have
that much time to kind of you know plot
out a character necessarily or journey a
journey with them I think it was with
Gemma and Sam who cast it I think most I
think with I think the credits always
got to go go to them because of you know
the relationships in all from not only
young to old with the relationships the
dynamics that we had in the film which
is well it sort of all kind of orbits
around is we're just so perfect and so
but working with the younger I mean it
was a case as we all bonded of just
having dinner together every night and
going up to the part of every night you
know just to join a crazy world things
are then its own yeah which is always
more case I think spending time together
and when you're kind of in such close
proximity to people that by the time you
can't help but think of things like I
think I became in that little ocean a
little bit Darby Jackie are you gonna
keep that going is up you know we
haven't seen we gets better job by
talking a bit about what you what an
approach you
projects you've got coming up I know
you're both very busy on you
Alexandra yes at the minute i I've just
finished a film called Cuban fury with
Nick Frost and rashida Jones Chris
O'Dowd and that seven sort of a romantic
comedy was really hilarious and I can't
wait to see Alice all centered around
South Sudan
and now we're working on a cello for
series called utopia and that's really
different it's all about it's like a
conspiracy thriller well I've finished
recently a film could happen if now with
a Kevin McDonald directing and Saoirse
Ronan which is a lovely kind of another
adaptation of a book and just finish
throughout this film is actually
untitled it's kind of got a working
title just finished filming in Scotland
with a director I could pull right which
is his first speech it's a really
exciting direct and he won a BAFTA for a
short he did a few years ago and it's
with Walt pecks film so it's a it's a
really lovely story about this boy up in
in Scotland and then after that I'm
about to stuff and could sunshine and
Lee Dexter Fletcher so I'm back I've
just comment and that's it well it's all
sounds great lots of luck with that and
loads of local cause of private vote for
a more natively ventures
you